hi everyone i am tom holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and i am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new adventure in spider-man no way
home i know people say this a lot but i
mean it when i say that you're gonna see
things in this movie that you've never
ever seen before i'm talking about
pumpkin bombs
sandstorm
the multiverse which okay you might have
seen them before but i promise
not like this and not together also
peter parker is finally heading off to
college and the word is out so yeah
everyone knows that he is spider-man
so throw your fan theories out the
window they're probably not true or are
they
and get ready to see one of the most
ambitious films we've ever made an
incredible story with lots of heart
laughter high flying action mind-blowing
effects and some insane villains no way
home is the culmination of the
homecoming trilogy and the start of a
multiverse of
spider-man is in fact peter parker
my entire life got screwed up
could you make it so that mysterio never
revealed my identity you ready
hang on
what just happened
when i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors looks like we got
competition
from every universe
i promise i'll fix this
exclusively at movie theaters december
17th rated pg-13
where are we going i don't know your
house no i don't know i thought you said
i really like me no well not anymore
hello peter do i know you we started
getting some visitors from every
universe this is all my fault
i promise i'll fix this
we're gonna get through this
and we're gonna get through it together
december 17